後輩からカントリーマウム２５０個貰いました
ご視聴ありがとうございました
皆さんお正月どうお過ごしでしょうか
はじめしゃちょーです
僕はめちゃくちゃ楽しく過ごさせていただいております。
昨日も、朝まで久しぶりに友達と
もう、死ぬほど遊戯王カードとかしたりしてて
有意義に過ごさせていただいております
今日は、ちょっと、あの、これだけは
今日はねぇ、もうねぇ、もう休もうかと思ってたぐらいなんだけど
これだけはちょっと話したいというお話があるので話させてください
一月一日、お正月早々に
やらかしてしまったお話です
これあの本当にマジで
久しぶりに、うぅぅぅぅわ　やっっっべ
完全にやらかしたって思ったことです
まさかの２０１７年一月の一日に起こるとは
僕よく行く遊戯王カードのお店があるんですけども
その遊戯王カードのお店っていうのは
その遊戯王カードってパックとかね、カード一枚とかでこういろんな売り方があるんですけれども
運を試せるガチャガチャ見たいのがあって
一回三百円なんですけれどもガチャガチャを回すとカプセルがこう一個出てきます
ガチャガチャのカプセルがポンと出てくるんですけど
その中にC賞、B賞、A賞、S賞の４つ、賞があります
ふつうね何回やってもC賞C賞C賞C賞つってC賞しか基本的に出ないんですけれども
C賞だともう普通に弱いカード１０枚セットぐらいのはずれで
B賞だとちょっといいカードぐらいかなと
ちょっといいカード３００円４００円５００円ぐらいのいいカードがあって
A賞になるともうなんかもう１０００円か２０００円くらい１０００円２０００円あたりのカードが出て
S賞はもう出たとこ見たことなかったですよ
エス相はもうなんか１枚２０００円越えのカードが３、４枚セットとか
一万円行くか行かないかぐらいがS賞であるんですよ
その４つの賞が入ってるんですけど
僕たまによく回すんです
よくまわすんですけども、ほんとにごくまれにA賞が出たり
まあ、何回か回したらたまにB賞がでてうれしいなみたいな
基本的にはほんとにC賞ばっかりで
結構当たりにくいんですよ
一回三百円のガチャガチャ、僕そのお正月の夜に後輩２人と僕の３人でそのカードショップに行きました。
後輩二人とか僕でねこうなんかいろんなカード買ったりして「エヘェ（*´∀｀*）エヘェ（*´∀｀*）」てこうやってたんですけど
でやっぱお正月じゃないですか
あ、初詣
もうちょっと人が少なくなったら一人で行ってきます
という話じゃない
一月一日だったからこうなんか運試し的なのがしたくなったわけですよ
で、ちょっと運試ししたいと思って、いつもやってる３００円遊戯王ガチャガチャのところ行ったら
一人の、男性がいました
多分僕よりちょっと年上ぐらいの方かな...
僕よりちょっと年上ぐらいの方が
遊戯王ガチャガチャ、ガッチャガチャやってて
もうほんとに皆さんの想像しているガチャガチャの３倍ぐらいやってます
もうガチャガチャをもうやばいぐらい３百円入れまくってやってて
ガチャガチャのマシンの上の方に出てきたカプセルがすごいおいてあったんですよ
ぱっとみ僕数えたところたぶん３０個以上カプセルあったんで
一万円以上あの人はガチャガチャやってます
その人何を狙ってるかというと、まあ間違いなくS賞出せば、早いタイミングでS賞出せば
たぶんS賞１万円ぐらいの価値あるんで
もう、１０回やってS賞出せば３０００円で１万円が当たったと同じで、七千円の特になるわけです
その人は多分、３００円でめちゃくちゃガチャ回して頑張ってS賞を出してこういい一年を迎えたかったわけですよ、多分
だって、僕と後輩がガチャガチャのところ行った時もその人めっちゃガチャガチャしてて多分３７，８回目ぐらいのところでやってたと思います
その人はそこでやり続けるべきだったのかもしれない
僕と後輩２人でこうガチャガチャのところ行って
なんか、運試しがてらまわしちゃうみたいな感じで話してたら、その人多分いい人だったんですよ
いい人で気配ってくれて、なんかこうガチャガチャ回してたんですけど
あー、百円玉ないなー、ちょっと両替機行ってこよみたいな感じでちょっと千円札を出しながら両替機の方に行って
ガチャガチャの場所を開けてくれたんですよ
多分そのガチャガチャの中も３０何回も回したら、中身が超少ないわけです、厳選されてるわけです。
それでも、その人は回し続けている
つまりまだS賞が出ていない状態で
僕たちにガチャガチャを譲ってしまった
そのなんか待ってる人がいたらちゃんと譲ってくれる精神はほんとに素晴らしいと僕も思います。ほんとにいい人でした
いい人でした、で、まあ、じゃあ、先輩の僕が「じゃあ、俺から運試しで回すわ」つって
その人が両替言った隙に空いてたので、僕がその一回回しました。
ガチャン、A賞
シャーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！あっ
やべ
あの人
これを出すために回してたんじゃないのか
やらかした
その人が続けて回してたらA賞出てたんですけど
たまたま譲ってくれた僕にA賞の番が回ってきちゃって
A賞とっちゃったんすよ
ほんとに申し訳なかった、僕はもう迷うことなくA賞の超高級カード
そこそこ高いカードブレイクソードっていうカードを僕は３００円でゲットしてしまいました
イェイ！
いい年になりそうでした
だが、ここで話は終わらなかった、残り後輩２人がいるわけじゃないですか
で、僕に続いてその二人も並んじゃってて、両替してた３８回回した人はその後ろに並んでたわけですよ
で、でですよ。あー一はじめさんおめでとうございます。じゃあ僕も回します。で、ちょっと気の弱そうな僕の後輩が
百円玉３つしかなかったらしくて
じゃあ、僕も一回回してみます。みたいな感じで一回回しました。
ガチャ、ガコン、S賞
（緊迫感のある音楽）
キャーーーーーーーーーーーー！
もう、ほんとに申し訳なかった
その後輩１回しか回してないから、３００円で１００００円ゲットしたようなもんなんですよ...９７００円の得
もう、その人も優しそうな人だったんですけど、僕の後輩がS賞出した瞬間顔が
はぁ
ってなってたんですよ
もう、もう誰も悪くない、誰も悪くないんですよ
世の中結局タイミングなんですよ
そう！タイミングなんです
多分何も当たってなかったと思いますよあの感じ
その人は３８回でしょ、一万３０００円ぐらい使ったんじゃない？
もうほんとね、あのほんとね、そのひ...とのもうねぇ、複雑すぎた
気まずい気持ちなのに向こう３８個C賞のカプセル持って悲しそうにしてるわけですよ
普通だったら喜ぶところなんですけども、その前に１２０００円ぶん回してた人がいたんで
すっっっっげえ、やらかしたなと思いました
という感じでですね、もうちょっと一月一日からすごい人を悲しませてしまいましたはじめしゃちょーです
でも、世の中、タイミングだぜ
たくさんガチャガチャ回した方見ていたらここでお詫び申し上げます。本当にすみませんでした！